Jessie J is not letting body shamers to
get the best of her I feel better when I
felt like no makeup on and I'm naked
which is probably a good thing the 30
year old singer has been sharing a
series of makeup free vacation snaps on
Thursday Jessie shared this Instagram
pic posing in a black bong bikini with
windblown hair while relaxing on a beach
she captioned the pic took ages to
hairspray my hair like that oh and for
those telling me I have cellulite I know
I own a mirror we love nothing more than
seeing Jessy embrace the skin she's in
while also being loved up by her man
just days before Jessie's post she and
Channing Tatum were seen taking their
romance to new heights
the couple was spotted holding hands
while exploring London together
here's Channing and Jessie smiling from
ear to ear while strolling through the
city streets the cute pair was first
linked last October but their first
encounter goes back to 2015 when Jessie
presented to the actor at the MTV Movie
Awards Channing Tatum
a source old ET Channing is really into
Jessie and only wants to support her
quote he seems to have become her number
one fan his friends are so happy he has
found someone she is showing the same
support to him our insider adds things
seem to be going well for the couple
quote Jessie J has had some very
difficult relationships in the past men
who haven't been supportive and she even
sings about them in her music my sister
told me
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]